congrats on playing a delicious villain
how much fun do you get to play how much
fun was it actually playing someone who
uh is you know kind of pretty evil but
also thinks they're doing the right
thing oh do you know what this was a
this was a big challenge but the only
way I could sort of justify it to myself
was that she was so thinking that she
was in the right that she was saving
people she so this was it and so it was
so much fun I loved the whole filming
process and that and having to justify
or having to give ownership to know when
making those decisions that I personally
can find quite tricky and horrible so
yeah it was great fun what have you
actually been telling friends and family
about the prequel series what have you
been teasing them it's like I've just
been telling them I haven't given it
away anything about myself or who what
Maryland does I've said oh it's um is
that 1 200 years before The Witcher that
we know and it's an Elven world so
expect ears
um and I'd say a princess who lives in
the continent and is in a quite a a very
a patriarchal monarchy and who wants not
to be married off as a pawn which is
what she's destined to do but who wants
to have a voice and be an architect for
the Golden Era that's what I've been
saying you have some fantastic makeup
and costumes
um what talk a little bit about actually
the makeup and the costumes just because
I'm assuming this Ada just it made it so
much easier to play this character oh it
was so special it really felt like a
huge collaboration between the different
departments costume and hair and makeup
and myself all making Merwin because he
has such beautiful and Brilliant ideas
about her that I couldn't even dream of
so coming together was amazing and I
really because we spent a lot of time
trying we were loads of Iris then
hairpin dresses and that was so exciting
and all the makeup Deb Watson and her
team did it was so intricate and we
spent so much time together it was a
great experience my last thing for you
um you have some really uh fun scenes
which was the one that you were actually
most excited to film you know when you
read it on the page you're like this is
going to be great ah
ah
well I got to sit on a horse which I've
never never really done and so that was
exciting and there was a noise that made
it rear up in the air and it like
stopped filming but I thought I felt
like Merida from Brave I felt like I I
Robin Hood it was great have you seen
any of the episodes what's your can you
watch what you've done and enjoy it or
do you just cringe as you're watching
something
about the storylines that I'm not a part
of that I'm gonna force myself to sit
down and watch it and I'm so I want to
watch everyone's work that they've done
all the like the costume the hair and
makeup the set design and that so I'm
just gonna ignore that it's me like it
anyway
on that note I'm just going to say
congrats and um thank you for your time